also man kann es makaber beschreiben als
abschiedsgruß der
terroristen muss man sagen an den westen
also an das glaube ich lässt sich das
gar nicht beschreiben es gab heute
morgen ja schon von verschiedenen
regierungen die hinweise achtung achtung
hier droht offenbar richtig terror und
deswegen die bundeswehr hat ja auch muss
man sagen im letzten moment noch kabul
verlassen können mit ihren letzten vier
maschinen die dann heute gestartet sind
und wir sind jetzt genau und der
situation in der man afghanistan
eigentlich vor 20 jahren vorgefunden hat
nämlich als ein hort als ein nest des
terrors und die frage stellt sich und
das ist glaube ich auch das fazit dann
relativ klar es hat sich in den 20
jahren einiges getan
vieles ist besser geworden aber am ende
gucken wir drauf und müssen feststellen
es war alles umsonst es war für die katz
die terroristen sind zurück und wir
sehen auch jetzt dass wenn es sich
bewahrheitet dass es sich hier um einen
isis anschlag handelt wie es ja
plötzlich auch wieder mit
konkurrierenden terrororganisation zu
tun haben die taliban auf der einen
seite die das land jetzt regieren wollen
und dann hieß es auf der anderen seite
die versuchen nicht nur die bevölkerung
zu drangsalieren und die letzten
soldaten aus dem westen irgendwie zu
vertreiben sondern auch den taliban
offenbar noch zu zeigen dass sie auch
noch da sind dann wird es einen blutigen
kampf in afghanistan geben
[Musik]